merci madame neuville la parole et à
monsieur arnaud viala merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire vraie mon nom est jacques j'ai
53 ans je travaille depuis 32 ans dans
une pme du btp où j'ai vu se succéder
trois générations de patron d'une même
famille qui ont tous eu leur entreprise
vie c'est au coeur et aux tripes
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que je vois mon
patron arrivés tous les matins on vend
du café en larmes parce qu'il croule
sous les charges ne trouvent pas de
boulot et n'arrivent plus à joindre les
deux bouts
son père âgé de 85 ans qui avait pour
habitude de nous rendre visite une fois
par semaine effondré de devoir vendre
nan c'est bien acquis tout au long de sa
vie de labeur afin de tenter de sauver
la boîte familiale
mes collègues et moi-même mort
d'angoissé à l'idée que notre entreprise
cool de ne plus avoir de travail mais
surtout de perdre cette partie de nous
mêmes et en face de cela qu est ce que
j'entends je vous entends nous présenter
comme remède en au problème la loi
travail qui parle d'augmentation du
temps de décharge syndicale et du
rémunération du temps passé dans les
associations
j'entends vos ministres en charge du
budget continuer de justifier les coups
de cutter qu'ils ont asséné aux
collectivités territoriales alors
qu'elle nous fournissez 70% de notre
charge de travail j'entends votre
ministre de l'éducation nationale parler
d'apprentissage tout en continuant de
faire peser sur les entreprises qui
veulent former des apprentis des
stagiaires des contraintes telles
qu'elles n'en prenne plus j'entends les
particuliers nos clients d'hier nous
dire qu'ils ne peuvent plus investir
parce qu'ils ont peur de l'avenir
peur du chômage peur du vide
déjà que des didier des maris dans mon
cas il y en a plus de 16 millions en
france dans les plus de 3,5 millions de
tpe et pme qui font vivre nos
territoires même les plus ruraux comme
celui de l'aveyron que j'affectionne
particulièrement et auquel vous
n'apportez aucune solution
comment faut-il s'y prendre monsieur le
premier ministre pour que vous les
entend dire si la parole est à madame
myriam
elle comprit ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député arnaud viala je ne
connais pas jacques mais je serais ravi
de le rencontrer peut-être chez vous en
aveyron mais sachez permettez moi de
vous dire que jacques a dû ressentir
notamment à travers le pacte de
responsabilité à travers le cic eux
qu'ils avaient un allègement de charges
peut-être que jacques a fait partie des
8 178 employeurs de l'aveyron qui a
bénéficié de l'aide embauche pme qui a
été mise en place
il y a deux mois peut-être que jacques a
bénéficié du plan tout pour l'emploi qui
a été mis en oeuvre par le premier
ministre
l'été dernier qui vise justement à
apporter des aides en direction de
l'apprentissage pour les jeunes mineurs
apprentis etc a permis aussi de gelée
certain seuil
et peut-être que jacques peut être
rassuré ce que je lui dire salissant de
malouas parce que en effet faciliter la
vie des entrepreneurs et notamment des
tpe et pme est essentiel parce que nous
savons c'est elle qui nous permettront
de créer de l'emploi et dans ce cadre là
qu'est ce que nous prévoyons pour
jacques et d'autres c'est que nous
savons que ce type d'entreprises n'ont
pas d'armée d'experts juridiques et vous
le savez vous qui connaissez aussi les
organisations patronales comme lui paie
à vous le savez à quel point la
réaffirmation des branches sont
essentiels pour les petites entreprises
passées de 7 100 à 200 branche est
essentielle pour éviter la concurrence
déloyale permettent d accord type de
branche qui seront directement
applicables au sein des entreprises est
aussi une innovation porter dans cette
loi et enfin permettez moi de vous dire
que jacques pourra aussi moduler le
temps de travail aujourd'hui au delà de
8 28 jours et demain sur neuf semaines à
porter des clartés aussi sur le pré la
prévision votive licenciement économique
permet aussi d'avoir un droit beaucoup
plus clair et ça permettra à jacques et
à d'autres d'avoir une plus grande
visibilité
cette minorité au-delà de cette loi nous
la mettons en oeuvre depuis 2012
et sachez que jacques peut ressentir
également dans une dizaine d'hommes
beast l'ap